So the example here for the study, I'm going to start with the COBALT study, which was a phase one dose escalating study for CD70-targeted allogenic CAR-T in relapsed refractory T-cell lymphoma.
Those are my disclosures.
I'm trying to focus on three areas here.
First, I'll mention the obstacles in making CAR-T in general for T-cell malignancies.
Then I'll give the examples of the COBALT study, which identified a new target with CD70 and has a lot of advantages.
The construct of this CAR-T and some clinical evidence and what we learned from that study.
And moving forward with the CAR-T landscape for now in T-cell lymphoma and the future direction.
So why it is difficult for CAR-T?
We have great success with B-cell malignancies, which is struggling with T-cell lymphoma.
And there are three areas.
The first area that we are mainly struggling with is the fratricide, which basically when CAR-T and T-cell malignancies and healthy T-cells share common antigens.
And you end up by doing this, the CAR-T itself attack each other while doing the production for CAR-T.
And that's a big problem in CAR-T and T-cell lymphoma.
And there is a way to go around that.
Other problems is the T-cell aplasia that you can develop from the CAR-T therapy.
Unlike B-cell aplasia, where you can replace IVIG, T-cell aplasia.
Because more profound immune deficiency that can be required to do an allergenic transplant afterwards.
And third, the product contaminations.
You don't want to basically transduce malignant T-cells while doing the process.
That will lead to the tumor escape, where we have a downgrade of the masking for the antigens of targets and lead to the T-cell lymphoma to progress.
And there is a way to go.
We'll go over those.
We'll try to cover during my talk.
So for the COBALT study, they used CD70 targets.
And we learned from that a lot of lessons from the CD70.
CD70 is a transmembrane protein.
It's a part of the TNF superfamily.
It's highly expressed in T-cell malignancies.
More than 70% of T-cell malignancy do express CD70.
Even higher in cutaneous T-cell lymphoma.
But also it's expressed on activated T-cells and NKs and B-cells.
And it's expressed on activated B-cells.